that is now recording again
pitch-perfect creating your confidence
pitch my name is Angela McDonald I am a
career coach and a corporate trainer I
started my career out in finance
I worked also had my own global export
business
I've hired and trained people in America
Australia China and Singapore and I now
work as a career coach and work in
leadership development and a lot of
presentation skills corporate training
and today's agenda we want to talk about
we're gonna start by looking from a very
broad view and look at a personal value
proposition and what is a personal value
proposition why do you need it and how
do you write it then we want to take
this personal value proposition and
start scaling it down to say how can I
use this as a framework for my elevator
pitch and to craft that answer - tell me
about yourself
have you has anyone found themselves in
a situation where someone says what do
you do or tell me about yourself and you
just freeze and you come out all jumbly
and it doesn't come out as confident as
you want it to sound I know I've been
there and especially if you've changed
your career a lot if you've moved around
a lot it gets a little more complicated
so having a very concise compelling
message is is really important and it's
why it's important to create your PvP
and use that as a foundation for an
elevator pitch for tell me about
yourself for a cover letter when you
have a really strong confident message
you can project yourself in the image
that you want to give others so today to
give you a little overview we're gonna
work on I'm gonna give you some
techniques and some tools on how to
write this how to create it then we we
might have time for a little bit of
practice today for those of you who want
to try out a little bit of the framework
but more importantly next week we're
going to have an interview workshop what
we're really going to focus on these
initial questions so I'd love for you to
join us for part two of this if you
can't do both parts that's okay at least
we can to get you in and you can
practice it on your own
so think about those questions what do
you do tell me about yourself
what do you want to do walk me through
your resume these are typically the
first questions you get when you sit
down to an interview there are also the
questions that can make or break that
interview in about the first 90 seconds
you're sitting there I was talking to
someone recently who is an executive
with a very large US company who says
they are now rejecting more people at
the phone interview stage than ever
before and I found that so interesting
to be like what was the reason why do
they think that is one they think it's
because a lot of people aren't used to
talking on the phone anymore so they
don't have the strong phone
communication skills that maybe someone
from my generation when I was 1/2 the
beginning of my life talking on the
phone all the time there was no texting
so it was a lot of phone conversations
so one reason is people don't have the
strong phone skills that earlier
generations might have had the next
reason is they think is because people
aren't practicing and creating some of
those fundamental introductory answers
to those questions so if you think about
it another statistic I've heard is that
most phone interviews the person
interviewing decides in the first 90
seconds if they want to keep talking to
you so think about that you've thought
about how am I going to talk about my
programming skills how am I going to
talk about the work I've done but you're
not gonna get to that stage of the
interview if you don't make the first 90
seconds so that's why this is so
important to prepare and get yourself
ready to start that interview you can
set the tone for where the conversation
is going to go so first let's take a
little pool now that we've thought a
little bit about these questions how
would you describe your answer to these
questions remembers things like what do
you do tell me about yourself what do
you want to do walk me through your
resume I'm gonna put a pull up and I
to tell me you will see the question
come up in just a second and I'd like to
hear everyone oh my pool is not working
today it's an it doesn't want to come up
so what we will do is we are just gonna
do it in the chat room let me go back to
my presentation let's get a one two or a
three how would you describe your answer
to these questions five stars it's so
amazing super confident I feel awesome
or you're like that's okay could use
some work or ah help me one two or three
type in the chat we've got three - two -
two - how do you feel about it a lot of
two's a lot of people think yeah it's
pretty ok a lot of several people got
the threes in there just thinking yep I
need some help totally understandable
so thank you for that input next time
I'll have my fancy pool working so we
can use my technology I will remind you
that the career coaches do not have the
technical backgrounds that all of you do
so that's how we run into our technical
issues sometimes so good I think that
having a personal value proposition and
preparing is so important and personally
just from my own story I've moved around
a bit with my family and every place
I've moved I've kind of had to tell my
story again and and figure out what I'm
going to do next figure out where I'm
taking my business and I really learned
that I really had to write out my story
figure out how it was I was going to
best deliver my message and if anything
you figure out how you're gonna package
yourself up and hand yourself to that
employer and don't make someone else
connect the dots or try to figure you
out I know for me especially coming I
lived in Asia for 16 years coming back
to the middle of America I told people I
lived in China for 11 years and
Singapore for 3 in Australia for a few
they kind of just thought I was you know
a little out there didn't understand me
couldn't figure out what I did so I
really had to put that package together
to make sure
they understood who I was do we have
anyone calling in from China or
Singapore Australia any of my former
homes please type in if you are calling
from one of these I'd love to know if
you were there from China Singapore or
Australia anyway back on
what is a personal value proposition
what exactly is it that we're talking
about it's essentially it's a confident
message that describes your strengths
and aspiration aspirations and it's
essentially the foundation for your
personal marketing pitch so think about
that again every company has its value
proposition right has they have their
mission their vision what they want to
deliver to their clients and this is
essentially the personal your own
personal value proposition what can you
offer that company what can you give
them what's your mission what are your
goals
so I'd like to know if you now that you
think a little bit more about that why
do you think you need a personal value
proposition and some people's reasons
might be a little different than others
but right now what do you think it is
why do you need it and and feel free if
you can't type in if you want to unmute
yourself we're not a huge group today so
feel free to unmute yourself and let us
know what you think why do you think you
need it again I said in my case I needed
it because I had done a lot of different
work and I needed to really make that a
little more concise to be able to
deliver my message today says elevator
pitches at networking events and career
fairs absolutely great for networking
someone says she doesn't think she
succinctly presents that information I
think that's really really common I
think that a lot of us think of course I
can introduce myself but I'll tell you
what I start every coaching session with
tell me a little bit about yourself
and it's you know and I'm not saying
everyone has to be super prepared even
for a coaching session but I realize how
often people are caught off guard and
they might say uh yeah I'm a programmer
I'm taking a Udacity course like that
tells me nothing right that tells me
this much about the person I want to
know I'm gonna I want a picture someone
says to become memorable memorable
absolutely thank you for that Brett to
be able to tell your story in a way that
makes an impact
absolutely Leonie Leila I'd like my
LinkedIn summary to be a little better
and from my website very good again
these are great things as you create
this PvP the places you can use that as
a foundation Julie to remain focus and
avoid rambling or going off-topic for
sure and I think that it's so important
especially in an interview that when you
get your personal value proposition and
then you you position it and create it
for exactly that company and you've
tweaked it a little bit so they're
getting the exact message and focusing
on the strengths you want them to hear
then you're gonna feel a lot more
confident and a lot more convincing and
hopefully avoid the rambling I know I
can do that as well someone says I like
that one and I just went alone so far my
value add in a company is broad and
ambiguous and I need focus and brevity
very good a lot of times we're in a lot
of different places we've got a lot of
different pieces of the puzzle we touch
right we have to kind of say okay I need
to bring this together and make this a
stronger message for this one person I'm
talking to
it's important to be able to expose how
valuable we can be and a big part of
that is how we communicate it absolutely
and brand yourself yes Anjali absolutely
brand yourself goals of a personal
narrative
listen listener to LIKE and remember you
it's the first impression very good
Jeana and for those of you who who might
be on that have had long career some of
you might be starting your careers one
thing I want to tell you is that I teach
a lot of corporate education in addition
to my coaching a lot of corporate
leadership programs and working on your
PvP and working on your introduction is
something that you will do throughout
your entire career because as you gain
more experience as you've gained more
skills as you take another Udacity
course you're adding value and you're
adding more to your story so never stop
working on this and as you go through
this little exercise that we're gonna
walk through today hopefully it'll just
be the start of something that you
continue throughout your career and to
constantly be tweaking and adding
different skills and and talking more
about your value see Isaiah says I want
to define myself in one to two minutes
and I want to keep the listener to get
interested and start a conversation very
good when someone just walks you through
their resume year by year and you just
start as an interviewer you just start
to get so bored right what's gonna spark
their interest what's gonna get them
really interested in you not what you
did in 2002 right it's gonna be what
you've been doing recently what work
relates to what you've done now maybe
there was something in 2002 that was
really exciting that you're gonna touch
on we don't want to go through all those
years and all that step-by-step we're
gonna give you a much more engaging
exciting way to give your PvP ok I'm
gonna get
I'm gonna answer one more comment here
it says what if you what if you think
your pop is great but it isn't how do
you know your pop is good Oh VP I can
guess instead of pop I was thinking make
your message pop well I think one of the
most important things to do is have
someone check it have a career coach
look at it have a friend look at it have
a colleague look at it and everyone has
value everyone has something to give
everyone has a story it's just finding
the right pieces that you want to bring
out in different conversations
I like this quote that I saw on a
Harvard Business Review article the
foundation for everything in a job
search and career progression it's
targeting potential employers attracting
the help of others and explaining why
you're the one to pick so think about
that again it's something that you're
gonna work on throughout your entire
career that personal value proposition
it's the foundation for everything in
that job search and everything in your
career progression I work with people
who are trying to move up within their
current company trying to figure out how
to do it how to move around how do they
and developing that personal value
proposition expressing it showing it
marketing it is really really important
so kudos to all of you who are here
today and working on your personal value
proposition
Gina says have a unique talent or
experiences that is immediately
memorable even if it's not tech based
that's great Gina and I think that you
know that's a really good thing too if
you if you know who you're going to
interview with and you do a little
research on them maybe you see oh I
realize we both went to the same
university or we both lived in China at
the same time or we both took the same
Udacity course whatever you can find is
that little link that could maybe
connect you or make it memorable is
really good
so again let's think about why you need
it
and a lot of you came up with I think
most of these so I think we're all on
the same track here but just to clarify
it helps you get really clear with your
goals when you see your personal value
proposition when you read it you believe
it you know it and it also might make
you think you know what I think it's
pretty good but what I really need is I
feel like I need an extra skill in here
I want to really get this extra
experience it helps you see where your
gaps are also and it helps you elevate
and push yourself it helps you
articulate your message with confidence
and like someone said earlier it makes
it helps you make that great first
impression and at the end of the day it
really creates the image that you want
everyone else to have of you remember
perception is reality you want to make
sure that the image you're projecting
the way you're packaging yourself up and
you're tying that bow on top is exactly
the way you want people to see it and
what you want them hand to see in you
so you see that the lady looking the
mirror and she's thinking I know what I
see but what do others see what did
what's that reflection back that I see
and I want others to see and and
thinking about your PBP is how you want
others to perceive you whether it's in
an interview or at a networking event
keeping a consistent image is really
important
so if everyone wants to if you want to
take some notes here we're gonna talk
about establishing your personal value
proposition and really we're gonna help
you walk through an exercise that can
get you started on writing this and
we're gonna look at your attributes and
your aspirations because essentially
your PDP will include both of those it
needs to include what those attributes
are what those skills are and we'll go
through and look at some questions you
can ask yourself and where to take some
notes to help you think about it and I
know because a lot of people think my
attributes oh I'm a I'm a data analyst
that's my attribute well there's so much
more to it so hopefully these questions
that we go through will help prompt your
thinking and help you think oh yes I've
done this in my work I forgot I took
that extra class oh that's right there's
a there was a project I worked on where
I got exposed to some some new
technology so as we go through take some
notes write it down start thinking about
the things you want to include in your
personal value proposition
so your attributes what value do I bring
to my job if you thought you know what
would my boss say what would my manager
say or what would my colleagues say is
the value I bring into a project if you
were putting a project together a
project team why why would you have
yourself on the team what are you good
at really believe in yourself and
believe like what value am i bringing to
this project the next think about what
do you love about the work you do that's
where that passion comes out that's
where that excitement comes out when
you're introducing yourself think about
the parts of the job that you love we
all have parts of our job that we don't
love right when you have that to-do list
and the day and there's the things that
always hit the bottom and never get
crossed out always maybe to the very end
of the deadline that you've set so think
about what you love what are those
things you like to do first when you
wake up what are those things you get
excited about going to the office to do
then think about what keywords and
phrases best describe how I'm known do
people say I'm meticulous I have a good
attention to detail do they say I'm very
quick at programming do they say I'm
very thorough do they say I present very
well think about think about if you've
had a performance review with a manager
what are some of those key words and
phrases that you heard that they that
you would believe your manager would say
about you and again at the bottom there
what skills and expertise underscore my
value I've talked to people a lot of
Udacity students who have just a huge
Bank I would say of technical skills and
some of those they almost forget some of
you sometimes forget how amazing that
really is and how having that depth of
experience or that breadth of experience
really gives strength to your profile
and even if there are certain skills
that are made
a little outdated but you used for a
long time you got used to
troubleshooting managing projects and
then you've started working in a new
technology that shows that shows your
depth that shows your experience and as
you think about these questions and ask
yourself these questions and hopefully
you're writing things down now in
thinking about it think also about soft
skills and hard skills right you're hard
your technical skills are your
programming skills those skills that you
worked so hard to build up and become an
expert at but also think about soft
skills are you good collaborator are you
good project manager are you good
presenter are you a good writer
like what are things that how you
communicate or how you work well with
others how does that help I was just
working with someone today talking a lot
about working with multicultural teams
that's a skill that's a talent that's a
value you bring if you've worked in
diverse teams or if you've proven
yourself to work remotely those are all
different skills and values that you
have
the easy one there what are my biggest
strengths very general question that
often comes up in the interview so think
about that really think about what your
strengths are and and I always say to
people as you go through your PvP and
create it I want your first draft to be
like let your ego be huge believe in
yourself like write it as if you know it
was gonna get you that dream job you
need it what you put on paper for
yourself as your PvP should be your
biggest ego should be your biggest
confidence builder now you're gonna take
that you're gonna tweak it and massage
it a little too to fit LinkedIn or to
fit a cover letter to fit that
discussion in an interview but before
you can customize it and scale it down
you need to have the real big picture
the whole picture I know some people
their personal value proposition is a
whole page they've written out almost
like a letter to their dream job their
dream company and that's one way you can
think about it the last two questions
here to think about what makes me unique
what really makes me special and what do
I do
that is fantastic in my job and think
about if someone was gonna hire you what
would be that one thing you do of each
day that you say you know what this is
what you're gonna love about me
I'm gonna stop here for a second that's
those are the kind of the questions I
want you to think about as you think
about your attributes to help you build
your confidence to remember it's okay to
be egotistical here and to think about
all those different things you bring to
that package to the table Leonie asks
should you adjust these attributes based
on the company or approaching absolutely
I think and that's why it is important
to have this big picture and have it all
mapped out whether you have it in a
letter form some people put it in a
almost a diagram form or they they
branch off and show their different
strengths so they can visualize it
however that works for you and I think
as you go into a company that you're
gonna interview for look through the job
description look at that cut those
company values what they say what they
value as a whole and then look at your
PvP and think okay what aligns here what
really aligns and it's also a good
litmus test to say you know it if
nothing aligns into those company values
and what I do and what I bring and what
I want in a job then that helps you also
filter out what you want to do and with
the companies you're really interested
in and the jobs someone asks what was
the category before my attributes it's
gonna be next we haven't hit it yet so
first it was my attributes and next it
will be aspirations any questions here
about the attributes as you think about
these as you I know it's I know for
younger people it can feel harder
because you think wow I just you know I
just finished school oh I don't have
that much of a PvP yet but you do you
have think about things you the way you
operate in a group project how you've
worked with people on teams and projects
and use those examples use those as your
inspiration and you'll find pretty
quickly after your first job in six
months
this PvP is really going to change
Sione says PvP will help and see if
you're a good cultural fit absolutely I
was working with someone recently and it
looks like she's going to have to change
jobs or companies getting sold and in
her current job
she has great flexibility she can work
remote when she needs to and those are
very very high priorities for her and
her life right now she's proven herself
as a very strong remote worker very
reliable she's gone into interview with
another company and they're very strict
on and what time you need to be there
and being at the office every day and it
just from a personal value proposition
what she can bring and what Shiva also
values does not align and those it's
really important to see that bulla asks
where does my PvP go well your PvP is
going to be it when you first create it
it is yours it is yours to hold on to to
to see your vision to create your
mission then you're gonna use that as
your foundation for all of those things
you have there your CV your resume your
cover letter your interview your
networking so think about it as if you
were let's just use what's a big company
we all know let's say it's Apple and
Apple has their value proposition and
they've got their mission statement
their values and then they've got all
these different areas where they target
it right they target it on how they
project their image in their marketing
and in their products and that's the
same for our own personal value
proposition where do we sell ourselves
and keeping that consistent message now
again it's gonna be tailored for each
one you're gonna bring out different
experiences or different skills you're
not changing who you are you've got this
nice big picture you just tweak it and
highlight different things at different
times any more questions about
attributes before you move on all right
you
okay now we want to think about
aspirations and the reason we talk about
aspirations is because if we if we just
have our personal value proposition
there and it feels very static then it's
not gonna help motivate us in our goals
and our where we want to go next in
interviews so think about asking
yourself these questions where do I want
to go next where do I see myself in one
year five years three years ten years
and what goals have I set to get there
and you know some of these they seem
like very simple questions but they can
actually be the hardest because I
haven't happened yet right it's where
you can dream a little it's where you
can branch it out a little and again
remember your personal value proposition
is about you also building that
confidence in yourself building your own
professional profile to make sure your
your collating and keeping all that that
data let's call it a lot of your data
people about what you've done and and
look at how that's gonna lead into what
you want to do next also when you see
what you want to do next and where
you've been that's also where we find
gaps right that's why maybe a lot of
yours are taking a Udacity course right
now you identified at some point that
maybe there was a gap you had or a skill
that you needed to be able to go to
where you want to go next
all right a little bit more on
aspirations get specific think about
what title or position do I really want
do you want to be a team leader a
director and do you see yourself leading
an IT team do you see yourself going out
and and having your own business someday
now again so there are certain things
you won't say in an interview but
knowing these and having these in your
personal value proposition and setting
your goals is really important to
helping you project the right image
think about what increased
responsibilities do I want have you
gotten to the point in your job where
maybe you feel like you're not growing
or learning anymore you're not being
challenged maybe you're busy it's
filling your day but you're not learning
anything new you're not getting into new
territory start identifying okay if at
some point I can work in this current
position or or grow a little what do I
really want to do what are those new
responsibilities I would want and
hopefully some of those others would go
away and next and this is where your
Udacity course really comes into play is
what new skills am i working on that I'd
like to use in my next job so I know
there's a lot of you that I talk to that
are let's say you're a software engineer
right now and you're taking these data
science classes because you want to
shift more into data science those are
those new skills that you want to make
sure you bring out in your PvP and in
your tell me about yourself to make sure
that they don't just see you as your
history but they see you as what you've
been working on what you may be you
aren't as experienced in data science
obviously as software engineering but
you're starting to make that transition
you're starting to get those experience
you want to use those skills someone
also texted like
as you plan let me just read this a
second planned my intro my story but so
how when you get on the call do you make
sure you you don't forget these things
and maybe I'll touch just really quick
on as you create your PvP then for every
interview you're gonna want to rewrite
it tweak it to be what you want to say I
don't recommend memorizing it but I do
recommend writing it out thinking about
again remember the first 90 seconds
first impressions you're setting the
tone you're creating this environment
for the whole interview so working on
that structuring it and if you have a
piece of paper with it printed out
bullet pointed your order or highlight
some of the words you want to make sure
you touch on that's a great way to help
get you started very confidently
so hopefully you've been taking some
notes already and thinking about
creating your PvP as you look at this
little worksheet try to think about
those top five and again there's a few
different ways to help you get organized
this is one way writing down your top
five attributes top five aspirations
start looking at that and how it aligns
another way some people like to find the
dream job imagine it hopefully you have
a real job description that makes it
even better if you have a certain
company or targeting and write a pretend
cover letter to that company and and
write your PvP and in that mindset that
helps some people other people like to
again do more like a mind map where
you've got yourself in the center and
you've got your technical skills out
this way maybe some project management
skills this way soft skills here new
skills developing over here however you
like to visualize it and see it to get
started is great then I do recommend
again writing it out see it yourself if
you looked in my computer right now from
the last time I moved and was looking
for new ways to grow my business I
probably have six different versions of
introducing myself in different
conversations where I was either
networking and/or formerly interviewing
with someone because I would want to
bring out certain experiences certain
skills that would I think would most be
most relevant to them remember anytime
you present it's what is my audience
need and what to know it's not what I
want to talk about it's not what I feel
like talking about from again 2002 I had
one great experience like I just want to
talk about that if it's not relevant to
that person I'm interviewing that
audience then I'm not gonna make that
connection
another person says are there any tools
you can recommend to help you identify
your attributes and aspirations I think
that one thing that is helpful
you know these tools these questions
going through these questions asking
yourself is really the first step
another way that you can think about it
is an exercise that I go through with a
lot of people is so if you've identified
your top five attributes your top five
aspirations then think about what have
been my what are my top five stories
projects experiences if someone came to
me today and said I want to hire you but
I want to hear your top five best
experiences where did you learn the most
where did you feel you grew the most and
write those out
was it a certain class you took what's
it a big project you worked on in
another country
was it a remote freelance work that you
did and write those out and think about
it in you know a couple bullet points on
each one and then ask yourself what was
my biggest learning outcome from that
project another thing to ask yourself is
when you okay so let's say you've been
on a six-month project and you finish
that six-month project and someone said
to you why are you better today than you
were six months earlier think about that
and think about Wow
like what have I done in these last six
months for me personally I could ask
myself so I've lived back in the States
for about two and a half years and I
could ask myself okay what skills have I
built what additional work have I done
would have been my best story since I've
been back that'd make me way better at
what I do today then I was
two-and-a-half years ago
and then you'll start to things will
come to the surface for you and talk it
out I think talking with a coach a
friend a colleague even a manager and a
manager doesn't obviously if you're
interviewing there's all those different
things but in your performance reviews
say you know what do you think I'm best
where do you see me going ask some of
those questions see what the people
around you see because remember we want
to make sure that that we're projecting
the right image that we want those of us
those around us and those people who
make those decisions to see in us and as
you think about building this PvP and
writing this and your we're gonna talk
about customizing it today about how we
customize it to go into your elevator
pitch and not tell me about yourself but
also think about when you and this will
be a whole nother webinar
creating that LinkedIn summary that
helps you again you're projecting that
image out there to people maybe
internally within your company it
elevates you in their mind when they see
wow I didn't know Angela was taking all
these programming courses and really
increasing her skills in this area by
the way I'm not taking programming
classes I've taken a couple little intro
let's say our two here or there to
understand a little bit more of what you
all do but that's about as far as I'll
probably go but ask yourself like like
what what do I want people to see in me
what do I want out there on LinkedIn
whether it's people internally or
externally alright
so own your story it is your story
you're writing the narrative to
summarize it what do I do well what are
those attributes what do I want to do
next what are my aspirations and if
you're not looking for a job right now I
still recommend putting together a PvP
put it starting to think about how you
positioning yourself maybe it's for that
next promotion maybe it's to work work
in a different area of the company
because if we don't visualize it if we
don't believe it it's likely to never
happen
so let's imagine you've all now I had
two hours to work on your PvP and you've
got it ready it's all written out sounds
fabulous
now what the heck do you do with it
again it's now become your marketing
piece it's your foundation that you can
tailor for your elevator pitch your
self-introduction cover letters and
Linkedin summary and even more so today
we're gonna focus on the elevator pitch
and the self introduction and again if
you didn't hear earlier we are having a
work workshop next week where we're
actually going to practice this in
breakout sessions with your peers you'll
get feedback you'll hear from others
another great reason to hear some of
your peers and other Udacity students
share their self introduction is you
hear ideas that sometimes you think oh I
forgot I've done something similar I
should add that in that's a really great
idea I'm gonna go take some notes later
and think about how I can adjust mine
thinking about that experience and I
know as we get older I was talking to
someone recently and asked if I'd done a
certain training program and I said now
I don't really done anything like that
and I think it was my husband looked
over at me said yes you did remember
that one you did last year so we forget
and so it's good to keep talking about
them and hearing others talk
so now the pitch you're gonna use your
PvP to create your elevator pitch for
those of you who might be unfamiliar
with the term elevator pitch it is
essentially a brief commercial
introducing yourself the term really
came from if you were in an elevator
with someone for just about 20 seconds
how quickly if you only have those 20
seconds what would you tell that person
so that helps you take that big PPP and
think okay I've got to shrink it down
because what you say in an elevator
pitch maybe at a networking event is a
lot different than what you're gonna say
in that self introduction and I think
that's where people go into an interview
not prepared enough because they don't
give enough of their story when someone
says tell me about yourself I often get
one of often here two two different
things on extremes in one extreme it's
an elevator pitch it's two brief short
it doesn't give me enough information on
the other extreme for a self
introduction I get a five minute rundown
of their entire history and resume and I
get bored out of my mind so we only ask
how long should that pitch be to keep
your audience engaged but not bored
a true elevator pitch and let's say an
elevator pitches let's target more like
you're introducing yourself at a
networking event it's at work with
someone who you just met you've gotten
on a new project with someone you're not
gonna give your big egotistical PvP
you've got over here in your private
stash right you're gonna give just a
really quick highlight and think again
it could be ten seconds could be 15
seconds when we switch over to that self
introduction in an interview setting or
even a career fair it's gonna be a lot
longer it could be a couple minutes at
that point so I'm going to give you a
format for structuring your pitch again
I want us to stay away from the old
chronological introduction and this goes
for elevator pitch and your self
introduction essentially think of your L
of your elevator pitch is this mini and
traduction and then you expand on that
for your self-introduction
so present past future I want you to
open with the present don't start out by
saying well when I went to college and
my university dadadada
when she did just pop in with the
present give them that relevant most
relevant highlight of what you're doing
right now
then touch on the past a little bit be
selective about what you might mention
that you've done in your past and then
highlight the future I'll give you an
example but remember as you structure it
present past future
so here's the before version this is the
chronological pitch I compete completed
my bachelor's degree in economics in
2010 I worked as a banking analyst for
five years that I decided I wanted to
start switch I wanted to switch career
paths and get a degree in computer
science and then I
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah right it just
blah just bores people what's better an
engaging pitch we're gonna start with
the present
I work as a data analyst for a large
insurance company I work with large data
sets to help the business assess
insurance claim rates in different
states prior to this where I worked as a
banking analyst primarily analyzing debt
bad debt rates in the corporate bank
that's my past next I hope to move into
deep learning as I recently completed
the deep learning Udacity nano degree
that's my future so that's a quick
little pitch that I might use at a
networking event when I've met someone
new I've used that present past future
format remember intrigued them with your
current work start with the president
touch on the past emphasize the future
so what do I say
what's my catch what's my hook what will
make them want to talk to me and again
that's where you you've created this big
personal value proposition you know what
you want to project then think about
your audience who are you going to be
talking to are you going to a interview
where you're introduced with many
candidates together that happens a lot
especially maybe in the consulting or
accounting world and if that happens you
don't give a 10 minute introduction you
give something that's a catch and your
hook someone said what's the pass for
that fresher or someone with no
experience your pass might just be
talking a little bit about your
education it might be you know after
having complete just recently completed
some programming courses now I'm really
ready to move into a blah blah blah so
the path might just be a little quicker
someone with a lot more work experience
they're gonna want to highlight those
big work experiences there they're big
drawers of Y that they're being
interviewed
again know your audience target your
message to that person and that when you
think about your message and that person
hopefully anytime you go to an interview
if you make sure you get the person's
name find them on LinkedIn get a little
bit of an overview of heart who they are
so that you can convey your message very
targeted to them with a little spin that
might help you and that will help you
convey your story with confidence
someone said what should be my presence
if I'm still studying and I'm undergrad
you are present then you know can be
that you are a student and that is okay
I'm currently studying this and that's
you know it's a lot different for like
people who are freshers and coming right
out and but you maybe you highlight what
class you've loved the most or what made
you decide to pick that major or what it
is you love about the current classes
you're taking and why maybe that classes
been your inspiration for wanting a job
with that company because or that
particular role so let's touch a little
on beyond the pitch and this is your
self introduction and again this is that
big question in the interview it's etic
and this is gonna be the extended
version of your pitch and let's look at
how that looks as we make it a little
longer because we want to give more
detail to the interviewer we want to
sell ourselves a little more we're in
the interview we want to give a lot more
information and again we want to match
specific skills in our background to
that specific job that we're
interviewing for so here's a version of
that pitch extended I currently work as
a data analyst for a large insurance
company I've been in my role for three
years where I work with large data sets
to help the business assess insurance
claim rates in different states I per
for segmentation and statistical
analysis using Python and R I'm also
starting to apply deep learning
techniques learned
my recent coursework at Udacity that's
my present prior to this Roy works as a
banking analyst for five years primarily
analyzing bad debt rates in the
corporate bank in my next role I hope to
continue growing in the data science
field and take on more responsibilities
into deep learning I think my advanced
data science and deep learning skills
well they allow me to jump quickly into
this senior data analyst role that's my
future so again these are all going to
be so different and and this I would say
is still a little bit short they
probably add a little bit more of the
past experience if they've had five
years of work experience but for the
sake of fitting on a slide for you today
I think it gets the point where the
order that we're going in and what we
really want to focus on so we're gonna
summarize here you're gonna set the
narrative and the tone when you have a
good prepared personal value proposition
you create that introduction at the
beginning of your interview you're going
to create a narrative and set the tone
for the rest of the interview you really
have that influence in the interview
process because the interviewer comes in
with so many questions they want to ask
but they also come in with hey I want to
hear what this person has to say and
remember it is the foundation for your
job search and career progression
it looks like today we don't have time
for breakout sessions I think that it
was probably a little more useful to
think about preparing this first and I
think what we'll do is come back
together open it up now for questions
for a few more minutes I want to give
you as much input and advice as I can so
you can leave today being able to say
you know I'm going to go write my
personal value proposition and I'm gonna
feel really good about it
I also recommend again meeting with a
coach a friend a colleague a manager - /
- to practice maybe your your elevator
pitch or your self-introduction whatever
the situation might be for you with your
LinkedIn profile tailoring that summary
and I think Brett will be doing some
LinkedIn webinars soon and again we're
gonna have practice on June 12 where we
will get into all these breakout rooms
if you haven't attended yet an interview
workshop they are only about 10 minutes
of me talking so you don't have to
listen to me for so long
it's only about 10 to 15 minutes of me
talking and the rest were in breakout
rooms practicing so I really encourage
all of you and hopefully we have even
more participants but and if you're
watching this recorded of course you can
still come anyone can come but I think
if you've gone through this webinar
you're gonna feel a lot more prepared to
create that pitch create your PvP and
work on that tell me about yourself
answer get ready to do that in practice
and you're gonna hear others they're
gonna hear you you're going to get
feedback and you're gonna feel a lot
more confident going into that next
interview
PvP is your personal value proposition
so I'm gonna open it up to questions I'm
just gonna make my chat here a little
bigger so I can see all the comments
coming in
someone said how can I answer how do you
rate yourself in X skill or technologies
that is a really good question and I
think that's a tough that's a tough
question to get in an interview also and
obviously there's different different
ways that to look at it I always
recommend giving creating your own scale
so let's say you ask me Angela how are
you and let's pretend I'm not really me
I'm I'm a super tech person Angela how
would you rate your skills in Excel and
I might say well let's just say on a
scale of one to five if one is someone
who my great-grandmother who never saw
except Excel and and five is a let's say
a financial analyst that's been working
in Excel for for 30 years and I kind of
make up my own scale
I consider myself about a four so tried
it to build your own scale and think
about where you might put yourself if
it's something that you're really
progressing in but you're not as strong
as you'd like to be then maybe I'd say
you know what if you had asked me six
months ago on a scale of one to five I'd
say probably at that point be a three
but I'm definitely getting closer to a
four and a five now so think about how
to to frame it yourself because if you
said to me how do you rate your Python
skills and I just said I would get
myself a two was that two out of three
two out of five so build the scale give
them some visuals there and and then
talk about where you are and where you
might think you'll be heading or maybe
you know what in my last job I would
have said I was only about a a 2 out of
5 and Python and now I'm definitely up
to a four and feeling really confident
someone said about progression of your
career what should I say if I'm not sure
I want to be a team leader in data
analysis or go to data science after
entry as a data analyst
okay so I think that gets a little more
personal specific and it Carina is
something we could talk about
specifically I think that definitely you
want to show that you want to progress
that you want to grow and thinking about
ways that maybe if you're not sure and
you could see yourself in either way you
could show your strengths and either you
could say you know I I love you know
leading teams and I could see myself
working in data as a senior data analyst
and managing a team but I'm also very
intrigued by learning more about data
science and could see myself there as
well so maybe that helps can you share
some ideas or strategies about thinking
about the hook how can we communicate
why people would want to talk or how do
we how do we get a hook in how do we get
people to talk to us more why don't you
know think about think about the
interesting story you have if you're at
a networking event it doesn't have to be
something specifically about you it
could be something about the person
who's going to speak or you just heard
speak something about the topic of where
you are if it's an added interview and
you're trying to really intrigue their
interest may tying something you've done
maybe to the company or or maybe you
know someone that works at the company
and you bring that up and and try to
just again get away from that
chronological introduction and think
about it as hey I'm interviewing for
this this person could be a new friend
it could be a new colleague what do I
want them to know about me how do I
really get them interested and again
looking at their LinkedIn seeing what
they've done looking at their experience
helps you assess kind of who they are
and at how you might target to them
someone says how far in the past you
need to go with your self-introduction
you don't want to talk about what you
did 10 years ago it's not relevant
anymore I think that you know think
about I know for myself personally what
I do is I kind of think of my like early
finance career is kind of this one
general bucket where it may be when it
was more recent I would go through each
job that I worked at a bank and what I
did the type of financing I worked on
where now I would I kind of bucket it as
just saying you know I had an early
career in finance which helped me really
understand banking and finance and my
financial analyst skills blah blah and
that's about it right it's it's it's
three seconds on started out in finance
and kind of like bucket that together
and then focus on the more relevant work
you've done that you want them to hear
more about oK we've got a few more
questions and then we do have to stop so
I'm going to finish these three that are
on there and then again please come to
the workshop next week where we can
answer more of these questions as well
so three more questions how can I
present my PvP with realistic
expectation when I want to join the
company with full intention to be the
interview as boss or hire overtime
that's a good question yeah because you
don't want the you know and I know there
was a big conversation on slack recently
about what do you do when you're more
experienced than the manager you know a
great leader wants to hire great people
and isn't going to be bothered by that a
boss wouldn't want to hear it so it's
really it isn't something very touchy
that to talk about and I think that to
show that you're that you're eager to
learn you want to grow you have
aspirations but maybe not going into
being getting specific with titles or
talking about
Beamer general we're use I'd like to
grow with the company I'd like to grow
my career here a little more terminology
like that can show you a smart of a team
player what if I am really low on the
scale and the technical skills and I'm
asked how you rate yourself okay so this
is a good question too I think that so
let's say someone did ask me about my
Python skills what I might say is if
they said Angela how do you rate
yourself in Python I might say well
Python specifically I wouldn't put
myself like very high on the scale
however I have worked a lot with R and
I'm very confident by you know I'm one
out of five I'm definitely a five and R
and I know from what I've seen with
Python so far and then it's something I
can would be really excited I'm excited
to learn and start working on so that's
that's one way you could bridge it it
fits an area that you don't even want to
work in and you have no desire just be
honest and say you know in terms of
Python I'm that is not an area where
I've concentrated I've spent more of my
time working on you know data
engineering and something over here that
you can switch the try to switch the
focus and get their interests on
something else where you do have a
strengths
last question what should I want to know
let's see what should I want to know
asking every about a company when
applying to position in it so I think I
like to break this into a few different
areas so as you think about and I'm kind
of thinking about the at the end of the
interview and they say you know what
questions do you have for us and
thinking about the questions and in
different buckets and you've got
questions about the job questions about
and that's like very specific to that
role I questions about the company
overall and then maybe questions to the
specific team or department and when you
kind of break it into those three
buckets it gets pretty easy to think
about the questions you really want to
know things you want to ask and I know
what I've done career such sessions with
people we've talked about
the I've shared with them some questions
to lead him with us start with and
that's something we can work on together
and it's a resource that you know I
recommend going in with those questions
have them all written down so you think
you have them in your mind but hopefully
during the interview if it gets
conversational you're asking questions
that that are very natural and come up
through the process if you don't then
reverting back to those questions and
always think about it you know
especially if many of you are making
career pivots career changes think about
if you're gonna make that move what kind
of company do you want to be with what
are you looking for so that you're
targeting hopefully the right job to
interview with to begin with and that
you're really excited going in and
you're just trying to learn more and
you're interviewing them as much as
they're interviewing you that takes a
little stress off and helps you approach
it a little differently I do have to end
our webinar now thank you so much for so
many questions so much engagement it
makes it so much more fun for me I'm
sorry we didn't have a chance to break
out but I feel like we got a lot of
information out there which should I
hope was really really helpful and a lot
of awesome questions up there you see
the career support email if you need
something more from us please attend
next week June 12th I think Brett if you
have the link that you can share in the
chat room so they can go straight to the
events page and RSVP now the interview
workshops really are a lot it is a
workshop it's a lot of practice it's a
lot of less me talking it's easier for
me harder for you so I hope you can come
and work on these skills and work on
those pvps
and share them with us and and share
with the people who didn't attend this
one how much work you've done
thank you all thanks so much
and we look forward to seeing you at our
next event thank you and Bret has put
the link in if you forget where the link
in if you go to the Udacity page and
look for events you should find it or
send one of us a message on slack or the
student hub and we can get it to you
have a great day everyone bye bye